[Music]
president Trump signed an executive
order today slapping tariffs on steel
and aluminum imports the tariffs apply
to all countries except Mexico and
Canada while they renegotiate NAFTA with
us the White House says the US now
imports four times as much steel as it
exports the American steel aluminum
industry has been ravaged by aggressive
foreign trade practices it's really an
assault on our contract it's been an
assault they know better than anybody
it's a process called dumping they drove
our plants out of business it drove our
factories out of business
dusty Stevens attended the signing
ceremony in the Roosevelt Room today
he's a superintendent at century
aluminum pot line and he joins us to
discuss what this move is gonna mean to
his company I think it's important by
the way to talk to people who are really
in the business instead of pundits and
analysts you're actually in the field so
you know what the heck is going on first
of all it was great to see that event
today but at the Roosevelt Room and you
got up and spoke the president singled
out century aluminum because of the
military-grade materials that you guys
produce what does this policy mean for
your Kentucky operations so right now
we're running at 40% capacity two years
ago we had to shut down 60% of our
capacity through the town downturn in
the market with the tariffs put in place
today we're going to get back that 60
percent we're going to invest over 100
million dollars to get back that
military grade aluminum so 100 million
dollars will mean how many jobs it'll be
over 300 jobs how important is that to
this Kentucky community it's huge it's
huge we keep talking about the 300 jobs
that we're going to introduce into the
community and that's great the biggest
issue here is we're going to preserve
that plant we have 200 plus employees
here right now without this Terrace we
would lose them jobs as well so in
reality we're saving over 500 jobs when
you hear people talking about this from
Washington or New York who most of them
have never been
in a manufacturing plant they've never
set foot in one they don't know people
like you they don't know people like
your family the community oh these jobs
are they're never coming back these jobs
it's time to move on to a 21st century
economy the manufacturing is overrated
it's all robots what do you say to that
wish they could walk in my shoes we've
said I've seen a lot in the last two
years I've seen my friends go out the
door not knowing if they're going to
have a job the next day I've seen my
family's been directly affected by it my
father worked at that smelter for 40
years he retired early so another guy
keep his job my brother he was laid off
during the downturn he didn't come back
to work so this is directly affected our
family not only ours but every and
there's over 300 other families that
were affected by this downturn and now
the Trump administration is giving it
back to us one of the other gentlemen
who was in the Roosevelt Room today I
guess we do not have the soundbite but
it was so compelling he got a priest
from the Union yes and he got up and he
said until you see the look of a father
looking into the eyes of his son and the
sadness of you can't provide for your
family you have six kids as his father
and his family at six kids and he said
I'll never forget that day you all it
was a area of speaking out you could
never forget that day and he said that
emotion what that does to a family it's
just devastating and it is it is having
to go home and see my brother tore up
because he's got a little one at home he
knows he can't provide for her he knows
that he's not gonna be able to pay his
bills from month-to-month and seeing
that day in and day out struggle it's
it's tough did you feel like a
politician before Trump came along
really understood this community really
it really got the core of American
manufacturing and how important it was
to national security and to our economic
vitality absolutely not
we've been trying to get something in
place for over two years and the Trump
administration in the last what 14 seven
months has put this in place and got
this going this ball rolling for us so
this is this is great not only for ha
before the aluminum industry in the US
and the dumping of a glut and aluminum
production worldwide from China to other
countries has depressed the price
American companies can't compete but
what what the critics of these tariffs
say is oh all the products that we make
are just gonna be a lot more expensive
now you're going to be hurting the
mom-and-pop consumers to what you what
do you say we have a premium product in
no way else in the world can produce and
that is the highest grade aluminum in
the world and it goes to our military in
our aerospace without that where do you
get that aluminum
we're not gonna get it from China we
don't want to buy it from China for that
oh hey dusty it was great to see you
there today man and keep doing what
you're doing it's really a pleasure
thank you